live had um little lunch break and also
fixed up remaining stuff on GPU drive so
we should be pretty
well what the hell is this Twitter's
stupid
um let me not like
that yeah so pretty much we should be
set to go on uh GPU drive just waiting
for to launch their hyper pram sweeps
pretty much I think that's my
task uh completed for them unless
there's anything else that goes wrong
with it uh so not bad about a day and a
half of work
for pretty much fixing that project
35,000 up to 250,000 frame steps and
Hyper cram sweeps integrated so that
should do very well for them
let's see what we're going to do next I
should check the Discord quickly to see
if I've missed anything here
okay
interesting I will review this
quickly let me
see let me do a quick eval on this for
uh Captain whoever's
around I'm always very very suspicious
of stuff like this
so I have no idea who these people
are
um okay this math is [ __ ] um
um see
our code is publicly
available
May so yeah they just didn't publish
their
code let me see if this is even
something reasonable let me see what
they're doing
okay what the hell is
this shared
block state for different discount
yeah okay so this is a dumb approach um
they correctly identify the problem but
the solution they propose is
dumb like you're not having like
multiple heads like this this is just
not a good way to solve this problem
this is work like we are going to do
some work in this area this is not how
you do it
and this is like a dumb way to increase
the complexity of your this is like a
dumb complexity increase in your
algorithm oh not this this is
fine okay so I checked that
um let me think what else I want want to
do right now
things there's a little bit of hyper
pram stuff I want to fix up and puffer
still
um there's also a new collab I want to
start working
on let me think what I want to do right
now I mean I always have like a million
different things I can be working on
um I'm just trying to think what I want
to do right now what I feel what I'm
feeling I would like to spend a little
bit of time on our hyper pram
stuff i' like break out to actually be
working you know
okay so let me think about this because
I know what the problem is I'm just
like I don't know how I want to solve it
yet so um I've been running these let me
explain the problem let me explain the
problem
here so I've got these experiments in
Neptune now they're very nice um and
pong works perfectly so we have one very
nice test environment there obviously we
have all the test environments in puffer
I just haven't like hooked them all up
yet um I've been trying to get breakout
to work
nicely but the issue
is that occasionally breakout will crap
and kill the
sweep um and it seems to be
because when you go to evaluate Breakout
you don't
get you don't actually get uh data back
you don't get like scores back as
quickly as you would expect now I had
this run
before let me just make
quick yeah know my Oxygen's good we're
good
um just tired after lunch I
guess okay so the issue at the moment
for some reason these jobs are getting
killed which I would assume means out of
memory it's actually weird now that I
think about
was I have had this window before where
did it
go well I know what it was it just I all
I got was
killed
case so this is the script that we're
running
and what was happening here is that I
was evaluating for a fixed amount of
data um and by doing that like I wasn't
always getting
stats out of the
environment well now there are a few
different problems though because the
stats get aggregated
okay so there are two separate issues
here the first is that for
performance I'm always sending
means of I'm always sending stat
means out of environments instead of
sending per agent
stats so I don't actually know how much
data I'm averaging over in the first
if you average in the C code
everything's fast
technically I could technically have it
be standard such
that the environments report how many
data points they're averaged
over and then I would have to add a
little bit of logic in my logging
that but that's only part of the problem
the bigger part of the problem here is
that this thing is just out of
memory which no that should never happen
is it just collecting more and more data
into this buffer hold
on let me see what's happening here
so yeah okay so what's happening I guess
is experience.
I'm a bit confused here though because
they should get flushed
well you have to consume the experience
at some point
right right here I just say get rid of
it pointer and step right data
Experience Store
yeah pointer and do
step so then
how what is it that's
accumulating sort keys
this is really Jank but let me see if
this
works the problem is it takes forever to
even get to that message
do so if this works we'll find a nice
way to clean this
and I don't want to wait for it this to
be this
though I mean for short keys to be out
of memory in me
is it possible the environment like
somehow
breaks and stops giving me
logs I should be able to see actually
because hold
on if I go to the
Neptune and I
have this point
score there a length on
this oh
this one
is yeah so right
here this looks like an environment
bug it's actually nothing to do
with anything I
okay so if I look
here this is 30 mil
depths deps
evaluated then it
took it took 13 million steps to get 100
points um but that's actually kind of
reasonable because again these are like
average points
so that's like going to just be a very
thorough eal so if I look data.
stats yeah so there you have all the
scores you can see this is actually very
consistent each of these points is
actually a ton of
points but that's fine if we evaluate a
little bit too long
I mean this guarantees you at least have
100 games of
breakout in the data but realistically
way way
more so that's actually fine so I mean
this comes down to an environment
today let me see if I can find
it very
rare environment
bug I'm trying to think how I even find
this
quick time for unplanned exorcism hey
Ryan yeah for some reason our breakout
has a very rare bug where like episode
length just goes insane and you stop
getting logs and crashes stuff um I
guess technically it's possible that the
policy is just like bouncing the ball
off the wall repeatedly and not breaking
any
bricks cuz there's no like length cap on
the
environment that would just solve it but
I want to make sure it's not a real
I am still very
sick code should be yeah but I think it
goes infinite or
something I think it goes
infinite like here I'll show you it's
very clearly a bug because look at this
so here are all these runs where it's
like normal and then you have this one
random run where episode length goes to
40,000
weird this is puffer
Atari so we don't have a time limit on
ours you shouldn't need
one uh this is this end yeah this is na
though this is uh this is our version if
you've seen
this and we have this and we have pong
right we have like these two classic
tasks we also have Enduro
let me see if I can figure out what
policy that
was infinite length yeah they can but it
it shouldn't be infinite length I think
it's probably a bug I mean look if I
load up the policy and it's bouncing the
ball infinitely then sure we'll put a
cap but that really should not ever
happen
like this could just as easily be like
you know some Edge case where it doesn't
reset the bricks or something dumb
least okay
so I just wonder what the IDS
are I figure out what id this is
hey Spencer I'm just fixing a thing with
breakout at the moment we have a very
rare case where breakout just like the
environment goes infinite and I'm trying
to figure that out so we can use it for
all of our
experiments I want pong and breakout
first and then we'll start integrating
the rest of them into our standard
sweeps foret where the IDE is on this
thing base
I don't know if the time zone is the
same it should actually just be this one
though shouldn't it January
13th unless hold on is it
this it could be this
one it's probably this
and
then let me see if the other ones are
the
same I do like
six okay so they all
trained
fully let me make sure this let me get
this out of this
screen
no this is
just
huh I think I know what's happening it's
just not
moving I see
yeah okay I found it
um that's really weird
so uh apparently you can just not fire
the
ball and if you run hyper parameter
sweeps right eventually you're going to
get a really bad set of hyper parameters
where the policy collapses to exactly
that I'm surprised this doesn't happen
with
pong oh there's no fire in pong it just
goes right
okay so we got to fix
that that's a crazy thing to have happen
could it's probably the easiest thing to
do is just remove the fire button
see where's this get used it's literally
just
here unrelated I was working on
implementing Omni and syllabus in terms
out for
crafter you can replace all the
logic including calls to
Foundation wait with 10 lines of if
statements Foundation model is just
doing it
stupidly that's
hilarious yeah I
mean I've mostly just been ignoring the
entirety of like language model rln
whatever research because it's like
these models are really
stupid um and it's mostly just people
hyping up writing for Loops over stupid
models
we're actually um Ryan we're starting a
collab with uh with
Flare basically it should have started a
week ago but
pneumonia um where we're going to be
getting like craftex and their Jack M's
playing nicely with puffer so we will
have like Ultra ultra high performance
crafter with puffer you'll be able to
actually use that as a baseline at you
know several 100,000 steps per
second it's just a matter of how long it
takes me to finish the backlog of all
the stuff I got to do first I finished
the uh the NYU stuff C based no no we're
just going to integrate their Jack based
craft de with puffer so it plays
nicely um but you know we have nice
train implementations and stuff so and
Hyper Prem wewe so we'll actually be
able to use that as an
environment um we're just going to make
like our stuff cross compatible for now
and then in the future you know I've
kind of put it to them that you can keep
writing Jacks if you want but you're
just making your life harder it's way
easier to implement these things and
see it's like it's just like I look
through a lot of their code actually
like the kinetics code and stuff and
it's very impressive like I'm not smart
enough to do that [ __ ] but like you're
kind of just making your life hard
because the project would be probably
80% easier if you just wrote it and
see but that'll be uh in a few weeks you
know and I got to get through the log of
stuff got a few things to do for clients
and then uh for the various Labs I just
finished well hopefully finished we'll
see how their experiments go but uh with
the NYU collab today we got GPU Drive
training at 250,000 steps per second up
from 35k and we got hyper parameter
sweep stuff integrated for them as well
so they should be running like hundreds
of billions of steps of experiments per
day
now see python jaes yeah there's just no
point like there's really just no point
to doing the stuff in Jacks it's just
you're just making your life hard like C
is really really
easy um it's just like I I swear the
reason Jacks exist is because like
python programmers wanted to write
something that looks like python but
it's just just don't do
it were you drinking coffee no I just
got a big tea mug
right this makes me pop a bunch and
keeps my lungs
loose one more day of
antibiotics toss this is
air this is literally air
yeah I swear I'm going to get banned for
that at some point where like people
think it's like it's a medical
device ironically this is the thing
that's keeping me from needing an
inhaler on stream because it's either do
that or have to actually have an inhaler
yeah pneumonia very bad I do not
recommend zero out of 10
let me think
here
one and I don't understand what the hell
this
I think I can literally just delete
this I think I can literally just delete this
everything okay so here's this model and
then this is six
and then this
one okay so here's the bad model but it
can no longer not
what are you working on more experiments
uh there's a bug in breakout
Captain the fire button you can just
never press it and it will lock up the
environment and make it go forever so
that's what was crashing my
experiments I'm just fixing that right
now that's very
weird let's see if it's
are you doing the uh The
Continuous versions of these
I saw that you were like messing with
that I don't know if you finished
them with this patch we should be good
to go for um experiments now on pong and
Breakout
probably will'll add an Enduro
next and then we'll see what else from
there seems to work haven started busy
most yesterday new mechanic I thought
that this morning fair enough no
obligation there's the second bot today
and my chat window is broken so I can't
even ban it [ __ ]
sake are you kidding
me I have to go into the twitch chat to
ban that
thing I can't even get rid of that
stupid
mess okay and maybe if I do it off a
race Ram
thing it doesn't even
show I can't even ban this stupid thing
to get the message off the screen nice
[ __ ] job R
stream
um that's so
obnoxious
whatever well it's just it's stupid
because
um the the chat overlay in OBS breaks a
lot it just like infinite loads and then
if you can't
click the message from the
chat I can't click it on the
stream
here you know why is this four update
EPO this is kind of just stupid
right oh I guess it's going to it'll
sweep this anyways though
right do I have upd pox in here yeah
okay I do have update so it'll sweep it
anyways that's fine
I mean we'll improve on this over time
but this
is at least now I should be able to run
this correctly let me commit this stuff
up
so I don't want to just run a sweep on
this now because that'll take forever
breakout takes a while I'll overnight
this
one
um to be fair I should have an extra
box I should just get the set up on that
think I conquered
oh
good yeah Spencer I played that game and
it's really [ __ ]
weird I played like the game it's based
on it's really
weird the game it's based off
of it's like the most Japan game to ever
Japan
it's like a normal puzzle game but made
incredibly weird for absolutely no
dubs I mean it's kind of just like an
easy puzzle game game where you just
it's an easy puzzle game where you're
forced to play very very fast for the
most
part I actually think Spencer having
played it a little bit that um if you
train on enough levels that you'll you
will actually probably get something to
generalize it's like not as hard as I
thought
but you're going to have to make the um
for bigger levels you're going to have
to make it partially
observable the way that you have the
state at the moment you're going to have
to make the oppos uh it's going to have
to be like partially observable probably
like you see five in each Direction so
it'll probably be like 11 by 11
by I don't know four or something
because usually the levels aren't very
deep
uh what was I doing oh yeah I wanted to
do I wanted to set this up on the the
machine
okay I don't think I'm doing anything on
that box right now
anyways I forget I have all these boxes
can just run stuff in the background
now you get a chance to look at uh I got
a chance to talk to Stone captain and he
basically says that we're not doing
anything wrong and controls just kind of
Jank it's literally
that so it's we're not missing anything
it's just the state of rl's kind of
[ __ ] for control people it's probably a
big portion of why none of their stuff
works as
well um the best thing that you can do
for that is if we just get a few of
these environments set up discreet and
continuous we'll be able to like we'll
be able to really get a good idea that
pretty quick
make sure I have this working going to
try the policy setup you recommended
would a Transformer be warranted
absolutely
not do curriculum learning before giving
it the
actual you should just autogen 100,000
levels and train on them is what you
should
do the thing that I told you where you
just like generate some simple levels or
whatever and validate them and save them
do
that don't mess with Transformers and
[ __ ] I'm going to you're going to make
your life hard for no reason
works so that's going to go over
here now we have this running in the
background at least o support request
fine let me look at that TR to run
puffer 20 demo only environment that
works out of the box in
Duro well they should all work out of
the box all ocean environment mment in
Native mode with m equals one worker yes
so uh Anna they are all of the M's the
new puffer Ms are internally vectorized
uh you can still run the multiprocess
but here let me show
you
like so here this is pong right and it
runs one and one worker so it's
literally just running on one core but
you see internally that one Co that one
m is running 120 uh 1,00 24 copies and
the reason that it's on one core is
because it's so fast that we literally
only need one core forward it runs at
like 10 million steps per second um and
that's true of most of the environments
as well a couple of them you'll see have
settings with uh multiprocessing by
default like I believe neural MMO 3 yeah
see we have two M's two workers so it's
double buffered async um but most of
them just are one now if M are not
working out of the box please paste
error messages because they should all
work out of the box and uh if that's not
happening I will fix those right
now I suspect probably some weird like
local config or setup thing but uh yeah
let's see what's going
wrong I have seen some like weird
compile errors that a couple people have
been getting I just haven't I haven't
been able to reproduce them but if you
have messages error messages and build
system details I can probably figure
that
out that' be a good thing to do
now welcome YouTube folks welcome twitch
folks stream's warmed up
nicely um I am mostly back since we have
a few people here I'm mostly back to
work now it's going to be a little
casual and a little lower energy uh for
the next couple weeks I'm still quite
sick I was in the hospital with
pneumonia was pretty
close um but yeah I'm mostly back just
catching up on all the stuff uh mostly
it's going to be a combination of uh
puffer Dev science side puffer efforts
uh trying to use all these fast
environments to make some progress on
the RL
front various just live uh support and
uh support for various academic Labs
we're collaborating with we did a bunch
of stuff for NYU with GPU drive on
stream earlier
today
um and then portions of client work that
are public will be broadcast so you know
priority feature requests and stuff I'll
be implementing uh features that have
been requested live on stream as
well I think I'm probably going to be
back to streaming every day now it just
might be you know a bit more casual and
and uh lower energy than normal but may
as well
broadcast and uh support requests will
continue as normal so code reviews on
stream fixing stuff as soon as I get a
stack trace on this I'll fix this um
that'll all continue as normal now
schedule's going to be a little bit less
rigid until I'm feeling better so it's
just kind of going to be whenever I'm
feeling up to it but hour should be
good still waiting on this support
message here
something I'm not seeing snaking
breakout what multiprocess won't give
stats game State failed to update all
right let me see
that that doesn't even make sense hold
on let me get back onto the main
branch I think you're right I think I
broke something then
okay so this should be this is confusing
but it should work
stats okay so Anna I see does this not
work as it as I'm seeing it right here I
have stats right here in
multiprocessing so that's a confusing
message um and actually that should work
I should set that up so it just
works so I can fix the error message but
are you not getting these stats
please post your uh you're like are you
on Linux or you on Mac like
hey any further progress from
going Beyond coding in different
games still doing the same as before
yeah well we're now using these Ultra
fast game environments that we have uh
in order to run massive scale
experiments so we're now gearing up to
start running like large scale
algorithmic experimentation because we
can run so many
experiments okay not getting any stats
eval game won't run
Anna what's your um what's your like
your OS and
setup are you on
Linux it should work on Mac WSL or Linux
if you're on Windows stuff will
break Linux abun 2 204 okay so that
should be
fine
um I'm trying to think how I can help
you eval game won't
run so is this what you're running right
here
I'm happy to help you help debug this
now but I'm going to need I'm going to
need the information for
stuff I don't know if there's like crazy
lag on YouTube you might want to try
twitch I YouTube also sometimes eats
messages if you don't see your message
right here I'm not seeing it
in the meantime I'm going to think about
how I have vectorization set up
uh Anna I'm I'm more than happy to help
you
if if you have um followup information
if you're still
here I just need to know like system
details and like you know what you're
seeing and stuff and I more than happy
to help
debug in the meantime I'm going to make
the uh the vectorization thing a bit
more
very
nice okay
so IPS not looking great YouTube lagging
posting to Discord sure um you can try
twitch for
faster stuff let me
see okay snake m not
returning I'm trying to think how I help
you debug this because it's
like doesn't work on your system works
on
mine let me try something real
quick what happens if you use Vex
Cal if you run a d d v Cal does it
like native it gives stat but not value
what do you mean it gives stat but not
value like native it
gives gam step still frozen
so like when you run it it
doesn't like what you get like one
screen of stats or something or like
does this thing get stuck and what
happens everything but return value
what do you mean return
value like episode return length score
is one of these
frozen I don't know what you mean
by let me see
okay so it
runs but you don't get
stats that's really
weird
huh and you don't intermit like you
don't get intermittent stats at all it
doesn't like occasionally print stats
there's not even any multiprocessing
that goes on
there
um I mean I can help you debug this
possibly this is a puffer bug possibly
this is like a weird compile like
compilation Quirk or
something um let me
see so like
right right
here if you can you put a break point
like right
here and see if you ever get
um if this ever gets
hit cuz this is where it should be
logging and if it's not returning logs
from there then probably we got to look
at compilation there probably there's
some like weird Jank scyon compile
bug that's really
weird I'm making the vectorization args
a little more intuitive in the
meantime yeah more than happy help help
you with this it's going to just take a
little bit of back and forth because I I
don't have a way to reproduce this
right so best I can do is
like figure out on
uh on your
think I met you for a tiny bit at RL
party nervs were you there yeah I was
there um also caught pneumonia nups so
that was a total [ __ ] show but
hey how's it
going we are back fixing this
ridiculously Cur field one day at a time
pneumonia I got yeah dude I was in the
hospital for like I don't know four or
five
days nearly killed
me I think I'm going to be re-evaluating
uh nurs in the
[Music]
future re rejects three papers near
kills me zero out of 10 do not
recommend I'm down about 15 lbs from uh
when you saw me at the
conference do not
recommend go to RLC it's all fun and all
RL
tell them to stop rejecting puffer
lib like it's kind of a meme at this
point it's
right submitting I wasn't going to
bother
submitting like it really like it really
doesn't do
much like publishing the thing they
really doesn't do much what reason do
they give some
[ __ ] the thing is it like it really
doesn't do much for me to publish
anymore right like I'm no like I'm
graduated
like industry and whatever like don't
really care whether your library is
published um it's just fighting with the
reviewers and wasting my time and like
pretty much at this point the things
that matter are like users um continuing
to like Advance RL with puffer and
Industry clients that's
presenting would be
useful yeah presenting would be useful
for yeah
Fair are there like industry RL people
walking around
there when's this deadline anyways I
mean I could like I can just resubmit it
and see if they actually like take it
this time
um February 15th 14th that's fine I
don't know maybe I'll spend a couple
days writing it up at some point
here I mean it would probably only take
me like a day um it' probably only take
me like a day to update the
submission it's just annoying because
it's like a waste when it doesn't get in
I I do a lot in a day um
Drive Amazon see like the really big
ones aren't going to AR going to hire
puffer anyways yet because it's too
small we have really good tools but like
they have all their own internal teams
mostly we're looking for people that are
like in Industry trying to do RL for
something and having a hard time of it
like those are the types of people who
are are perfectly suited for puffer
support contracts I mean we can do a lot
we can really make a huge difference for
like companies that are trying to do
RL um for not a lot of money that's kind
of the
target cheap RL yeah but like it's
you're we're not really looking for RL
companies right like they're all going
to want to do their own thing we're like
mostly looking for companies that like
have a problem for which RL is would be
useful and they're just having a hard
time of it
Amazon mostly legal that stops us from
using whatever packages I mean all of
our stuff with puffer is free and uh
free and open source so like you can
just look at it and try this stuff out
for free and
um I mean if you want like extras right
priority features uh integration
assistance with a specific project or
whatever that's the only thing we charge
for I mean to give you an idea just in
the last day and a half I took GPU drive
from 35,000 to
250,000 steps per second training uh and
got them like proper hyper parameter
sweep integration and stuff uh all
logged and track so they're going to be
running like hundreds of billions of
steps of experiments per day now with
that package vetting team H yeah that's
a
pain can't really help you on compliance
side stuff
I know puffer is a small company we move
really fast with our tools
um you know if that works for you then
works for us if it doesn't then it's
tougher I had it breached in Amazon as
well last year I think massive success
be bigger than this
year where is it again is it somewhere
saying
Alberta you can understand I'm not
exactly in uh a mindset to want to be
traveling at the moment so maybe by the
time it actually is I'll want to
I basically for the next few months
don't really want to be doing anything
other than just like building puffer and
trying to get my body back in shape
after
pneumonia um I mean it's going to take
like months of training to get my health
back just ordered a whole bunch of gym
equipment last
night okay it
reaches hold on let me read this message
get all the stuff out of the
way it reaches the step
function observations do not seem to
heck yeah Ryan I was only at nurs for
three
days still nearly killed
me
um what happens if you recompile are you
using this from Source or from the pit
package if you're using if you have this
cloned can you
rerun
cleanly because it seems to me that like
something's just screwy and it's not
compiled right or
I'm trying to think how to help you here
like if you have
this I mean if you have this like on a
remote box I can like log into and look
at I'd be happy to do that I'm just
trying to think what I can do for you
here because
like I something's like clearly built
wrong or something here um I'm trying to
think if there's anything else that this
could be
observations that's got to be some weird
compile bug because the way that it
works with puffer
um we allocate all the memory from
Python and then we pass a pointer to
that memory to C
and then C populates that memory so some
wires are crossed or something if that's
not
happening like If This Were a
multi-processing bug okay you know maybe
that's a system dependent thing but this
is like this should just
like what is this going to use I think
this uses
GCC it should use GCC I think by
default what's your GCC version
like the only thing I can think of is
that this is like some weird C compile
bug
it's just a p it's just an
install can you try to get
[Music]
um can you try to like upgrade GCC and
recompile and see what
happens actually let me think maybe I
can downgrade my
GCC
9.4 that would be a nicer thing for me
to do
more
specific see
is I don't want to have to reset up all
puffer like torch and stuff
I've not had to do
this
works not
GCC I'm trying to think what else this
could
be I would think that would be the only
thing it could
be does it comply with
GCC is it compiling with
cl
[Music]
exensions let me see
x86 okay so it's still using the wrong
one
so now for sure we're compiling with
your version of GCC
works I'm trying to think what I can do
for you because I can't figure out
maybe
3.1.1 of
scyon
3.0.11 right what about setup tools do
you have a different setup tools
I'm trying to reproduce your issue I
just compiled it though on I just went
and got an old an old version of
GCC still works on
95 um
the fact that Enduro
works I know that there's there's like
some weird name conflicting bug with
like the step function but I can't
figure out what was the trigger for it
there was like some Niche compilation
bug but I couldn't figure out how to
reproduce it that's probably what's
happening what's your set I I yeah tell
me your setup tools version in case that
that's
it I'm going to be right back I'll use
the restro real
I think it's probably
this oh here's my condo list
perfect setup Tools in here so basically
the only thing I can think of um there's
like some
weird compilation thing where on some
systems um somehow like scyon names
conflict with C function names but I
have no idea like I've seen it a couple
times but I have no idea how to
reproduce it so around 75.1 point0 which
should be totally
fine um
version I'm going to just throw it into
GPT it's like the long shot
but let me see
see
[Music]
I can try this small setup different the
setup tools version change I'd be really
surprised if that's what it
oh you know one thing that you can
do um if you remove the build
directory so if you remove the build
directory like I just did and you
recompile you'll get all this these
messages I'd like you to post like one
of these lines like for snake or for
whatever environment I want to see if
you're using GCC or if you're using some
weird compiler
because it could be compiler
difference I'll test setup.py in the
meantime okay stable under the setup
tools as
well yeah let me see what compiler
you're
using T the full that will also
work build output yeah Captain do you
have any idea what this it's so what it
seems like based off of what I saw from
beton people um and I'd like to see the
Full Compilation message because I might
be able to see it from there but there's
this weird thing where it seems like
scyon first of all the scon step method
is it's a method of a class so it should
have its own name space um and then I
think even on top of that syon and C
should have separate name
spaces um but but somehow like they're
getting overwritten such that you can't
have a method called step in the C file
and in the scyon file which is why I
think uro probably works because bet
like I bet just like Band-Aid patch made
the names
different doesn't have named faces well
but C is going to have a function called
step and then scyon uh scon has a
function called step that's part of a
method so it should assign that a
different
name and does on like almost anything
you can compile there's like some weird
compile
bug I'm actually I'm curious to see what
the uh the compile line messages are if
I can get that Trace
it's got to be compiler difference
right maybe
like maybe theirs is compiling with
clang or something and clang is being
weird
in the meantime let me look at
this Okay so we've got breakout
running let's
see I should have slack messages was one
be sweeps as
well to look at in the meantime
yet I don't see any uh I haven't gotten
any messages
yeah right
oh hold on
here
building GCC hold on what the
GCC
H dash P thread
well this is a dramatically different
call
Signature
I so we get
f r
compile well I'm trying to see what even
like I don't even know what to
necessarily look for here right like you
can see right here
so we're both running GCC this is just
Nas to GCC
see but then all the flags are
different what would cause these flags
to be
different like why would the flags be
this different right
Pon 311
yeah it's what we
use nice job open AI they can't even
freaking
this try this I you know I don't know if
this actually makes any sense the
suggestion cuz I think he is using the
right
GCC I think
it's is it like Anaconda setup or
whatever
works or rather if it doesn't if I can
reproduce
this did not expect to be
testing fixing cond
added parallel axis I see that's
fine cool
running very
nice W this is
already could already just Auto solve
look at
that perfect
don't have multiple
GCC yeah let me see if an aond if
resolves
this okay so now this doesn't even look
like it
runs it just
so multi well it doesn't nothing runs at
all for
me
um yeah this just doesn't run at
all you sit in dir runs
right yeah so when Duro
runs and like if I do
pong okay so this is definitely the
bug so
uh if you want it to work immediately
don't use cond let me see if I can
figure out why cond is breaking
everything that's
insane oh it just didn't
build I don't have there's no build
yeah so that just doesn't run straight
up thees snake
so first of all why is Con of give you
all these different flags in the first
what is
this why does it do it
twice I just do this
that
it's not actually building
it why does it
think we get this
one this
so now I should be able to remove this
build
it now it's still
there okay so now I've built this thing
manually okay and I can confirm that
still the same good
this is truly evil right here is what
this
is
why is this included so many times like
did it just spaz
out look IE
system this is literally doubled
hangs let me just see what flags are
missing completely so
RB okay what other
flags W
eror format security
d
g d f f
b code generation
conventions F stack protector
is here's the one that should work right
this is this this is the one that should
work right
here so let let's see what happens if I
run
error uh
that's I should change this to 312
okay so I run it like
this it still not
work okay now this is weird because now
it's running with the
same compilation
settings as
before remove this make sure it's not
getting C
yeah so not it's not even the
flags um it's not even the flags because
on hold
on
here that's
one and the other one is here
Li it does it twice for no freaking
reason you
Flags
um let's see if this
works the goal is to figure out what
Freaking Flag is wrong and how I can get
cond to stop doing
one man it's crazy I don't get errors on
this just silently
fails so we want
this python
I mean unless it's
like does this not exist is this site
package like just not
there me
see Honda web
by the way this will work immediately
for you outside of
condo
um I'm just trying to figure out why it
doesn't work in
only thing that's different is the
python version here
much the fact that it doesn't build with
this like this is Anaconda python but
everything
else everything else should
be as it was
before what virtual M no virtual M we
just have uh either just system python
or we have a Docker container we ship
that has everything
pre-built and if you have a Docker
container then cond and virtualization
is just
redundant I mean should work with
literally anything other than cond I'm
trying to figure out what's wrong with K
it's like cond is doing something really
screwy and I can't figure out what
I mean a lot of people use cond so I
would like this to work but I like
it's I don't know what it's
doing I'm going to try now hold on let
me try going back
to okay
taking the exact command
here let me see if now this builds
manually it build
I don't understand how this is like not
putting a file and just not giving me an
file
oh that's so
thing okay can we
train after all this
work
okay this compilation does
this one doesn't
work all
right all right and and then if we
do 1
two okay so we
have yeah this
file so this
command this command these commands work
these commands
don't um
including wanted your opinion on
something I've been working on using RL
for board game Katon cool environment
I've been using rust because I heard
compiled way to go not fam
puffer puffer help me create the
environment would it help um yeah if you
look at the way that we write our
examples like all of our environments we
write like low-level compiled
environments I suggest see over rust
because it's easy rust is for people who
like pain for no reason um if that's
your thing then sure go ahead but it's
generally easier and faster to just
write stuff and see
and we have lots of examples on exactly
how to put together ridiculously high
performance reinforcement learning
environments perfect yeah
I mean you can use you can do Rust if
you want it's just like I don't know I
don't think for this type of Dev it buys
you anything I think it generally just
like gets in your way for the sake of
things that you don't care about um if
you look at like the sea environments we
have they are like so easy and so simple
to write and read they taught us rust
and
uni I don't know R rust is kind of like
a fancy trick language it's it just like
it's so heavy and it just forces you to
write code in such an obnoxious way um
and it gets in your way and makes stuff
slow in the process it's
like for me it's way easier to just deal
with memory and just write dead simple
code
um I mean there's literally nothing
fancy about it like you can read the
code and like you'll immediately know
what's going on cuz there's just there's
nothing there to be
complicated like there's a tenth of the
number of language features as you need
to know and
rust I know I am not a rust
enjoyer do you think I should work on a
starter easier RL project before I
tackle a complex game like this if
you're not a very experienced programmer
then yes absolutely if you're not a very
experi like a very very experienced
programmer then yes I would suggest
making a much simpler RL environment um
and like getting like go through the
process of making an RL environment like
something that's going to be on the
order of 400 to 1,000 lines um something
you'll enjoy something you can do in
like a week and you know go through the
process of getting an RL agent training
on it defining all the spaces and all of
that EXP experienced programmer just not
RL specific how experienced is
experienced
like have you been writing code for 10
plus
years Katan is not an easy game to set
up for RL
I haven't really played much Katan
so Fang you can try it if you want um
the things that are going to be hard um
the action space for Katon I have not
played anywhere near enough Katon to
know to be fair but like defining
observation and action spaces for Katon
is going to be pretty hairy
um you're basically going to have to
think about how
I guess the way to think about it would
be like how do you implement if Katon
were a Game Boy game right or like Katon
had to be just played with like the
number keys or whatever or maybe arrow
keys and num Keys how would you
implement it that's that'll be the
tricky part about that in addition to
implementing you know the whole
game I'd have to play some Katon I've
played it like maybe
once I mean it depends if you want to
just take on a big project right away
you can do that um I generally suggest
people make like a simple cool RL
environment just so you can get like
some experience on the books and have
something working end to end and not get
frustrated but it's up to
you some existing
environments oh yeah you can have look
at this so and I code review everything
that gets
contributed
um so puffer ocean like look at all
these environments here so like here's
uh here's
snake it's one C file 300 something
lines and you can just read through here
and see how simple it
is if you want something dramatically
more complicated we go all the way up to
like neural MMO
3 this is a full MMO in like less than
3,000 lines one file
so you can go from very very simple to
very very complicated and you have
examples for
everything plus I'm streaming all this
Dev half the time so it's easy to get
help I'm particularly helpful if people
uh to people who contribute the ends to
Puffer
that is when I'm not fighting ridiculous
compile bugs Honda is
evil got it maybe I can add aim K after
some dum projects yeah I mean there are
lots of projects you can do if you're an
experienced programmer like i' I don't
know I've wanted a maze environment for
a while if you want to do like
procedurally generated maze environment
that's probably like a 400 line
M um that would be pretty
cool that's like something that can be
done pretty
easily if you have other ideas that's
cool
too I'm eventually going to want
somebody to throw together a basic FPS
that's going to be a little harder I
have to think about how you do
observations for
that there's lots of stuff that can be
done lots and lots of stuff and it's a
great way to get into RL it's really the
best
so literally the only difference between
these
two the only difference between these
two is cond of
python and it doesn't work
I there's no way that this does anything
but let me
this is crazy rabbit
hole freaking crazy crazy Rabbit
Hole the things I do for my users here
okay so now we have we've got this
version here which is going to
why is there no 311 in the freaking
Anaconda include
is it in
[Music]
so it's not going to be in here either
is it this [ __ ]
thing
3.11 luckily it's only
here okay
and I also have to
on all right um I got to run I got to
fix this later
it is my birthday today and I'm being
called to not just write code all night
um yeah so I will fix this through the
evening or whatever um really like to
get condo working I have no idea what's
wrong with it I'm hoping that what's
going to happen is I'm going to find
whatever bad Flags it's using thank you
I'm going to hopefully find whatever bad
Flags this thing is using and just like
add something to up to prevent cond from
breaking itself but um we will see
thanks man I'll be back in a bit
um we'll see maybe I'll stream later
maybe I won't it depends how tired I am
uh hopefully I can get this thing sorted
though uh in the meantime we still have
these experiments going in the
background so this will be a nice test
of our hyper parameter sweep so that's
running and
then uh hold on damn it they still
dropped my
perf
well there's some cool hyper pram sweeps
on here
um anyways I got to go I'll be uh I'll
be around later Anna use uh I will be
around in the Discord for now just use
anything but cond and it'll work and if
it doesn't let me know I'll try to fix
cond it's real deep in the weeds with
what's going on with compile cond is
just like a horrible broken piece of
software um but yeah I will try to fix
that anyways thanks for tuning in folks
I'll be streaming a lot more Dev uh over
the coming weeks now I'm back